>> It's great to be here
today with you, Dario.
It's great having a Director
of Safety with us.
In this case, Director of
Safety of AI Systems in OpenAI.
Thanks for joining us today and
just give a fabulous lecture,
and folks out there who
see this fireside chat,
who have not senior lecturer yet,
this is a pointer to the lecture.
What remarkable is in terms
of similarity between us is
that we've had similar pasts,
just talk a little bit about how
you got to where you are now.
It's an interesting trajectory
towards the world of
intelligence and
into their notion
of onto safety and robustness.
But you started out in physics,
and tell me a bit
about how that progressed
to where you are?
>> Yeah. So, I mean, I
think when I was younger,
I really wanted to figure
out how the universe works,
why I wanted to be
a physicist wanting
to drive fundamental laws.
Then so I did
my undergrad in that.
When I went to grad school,
which was also in physics,
I got really interested
in what can,
both the methods and the
recording devices from physics,
tell us about neuroscience
in the brain and in intelligence.
I thought of doing
AI at that time,
but I felt like I really wanted
to understand the brain because
it's the only existing example
of a truly intelligent system.
So, I spent a fair
amount of time doing
that in grad school,
did kind of a postdoc in
computational biology,
and then through Stanford,
got to know about
speech research project going on
at Baidu under rendering.
So I was there, then I
was at Google for a year,
and a little over a couple
years ago, I joined OpenAI,
and sometime around
where I was working
on things at Baidu and Google,
just got a lot of experience
with the brittleness
of neural nets.
In one sense, they're
very robust and powerful.
But that when you go off
some given distribution,
they don't do so well and
that it's hard to
understand really what's
going on inside them,
and particularly that
in the long run as
we make systems more powerful.
These problems are only
going to get worse,
so I decided that was
what I wanted to work on.
>> But going back, it
will come back to where
you are now in the great research
that you're doing with your team,
but going back to
this decision or
this deep curiosity about
what's going on in
brains and neurobiology,
what's the spark of that?
>> Yeah. I mean,
when I got to Princeton
for grad school,
there were a few biophysicists
there working on
models of neural circuits
based on statistical mechanics
and having done a fair amount of
statistical mechanics
as a physicist.
I was really interested
in what can we say
with these kind of
statistical models
that are based on
thermodynamics about the brain,
can it give us any insight.
In vague terms, a lot of
people were analyzing
single neuron saying,
"Here's a circuit,
this neuron does this,
that neuron does this."
Maybe things are more
about the population and
the statistical properties and
that seem very intuitive to me,
so I kind of wanted to devote
myself to looking into it.
>> Do you feel like in
advance of your work in AI,
you came away with
any intuitions or
insights about what
the heck's going
on in vertebrate brains?
>> Yeah.
>> If any brains will throw
invertebrates in there too?
>> Yeah. It's hard.
I mean, I think
one lesson I learned
about the field of
neuroscience is
that it's very limited by
our ability to measure
what's going on,
and the brain theory
is overdetermined.
It's actually very, very much
like in particle physics,
where you can come up with
a whole bunch of theories,
but if you only have
a little bit of data,
then there are too many theories
that could fit that data.
So, in neuroscience, we're
always trying to get more data.
I spent a lot of
my PhD trying to do
that with at least some success,
although much less than
I would have hoped
for than I think the field needs
to really understand things.
I did get some instincts that
things like simple reinforcement
learning approaches,
maybe in some ways
on the right track.
If you look at hippocampus,
there are things that look like
temporal difference
policy updates
happening that looks
surprisingly much like it.
So, the idea that
their RL is a piece,
which really has ended up
being right in the field,
it was like one of
the lessons that I drew.
>> So, it was great reading
about your earlier work
and the work he did during
grad school in neurobiology.
It was fun to talk
to you over lunch,
just now where we compared
some notes in that.
At Microsoft Research, we
have had a collaboration with
Bill Kristan's team at UCSD
taking the latest in ML tools,
machine learning
and visualization,
to try to understand what's going
on with sets of neurons,
in this case, in
the medicinal leech
and you working in salamander.
>> Yeah. So, yeah.
I've done some work
on salamander retina,
and really just the logic
there was to try and
understand the nervous system
of a complex animal by taking
a separable piece of it,
where the salamander retina,
you can fully control what
goes into the salamander retina,
and then look at what
goes up the optic nerve.
So, you have this kind of SandBox
that's an isolated piece
of the brain.
You can control the inputs,
observe the outputs,
and look at what's happening
to every neuron in-between.
What we focused on was trying to
record from a large number
of these neurons and saying,
"What is the whole population
of neurons doing?
What is it coding for?
How does it collectively
communicate information?"
That got me thinking
about these kind of
higher-level questions
about intelligence.
>> Yeah. I just personally
been blown away by what
evolutionary biology
discovered they could do with
cells and tangles of
cells to do cognition,
whether it be invertebrates
or vertebrates.
To me, I would certainly
have stuck with
neurobiology if I thought I
can make better progress.
I don't know if you feel
the same way or not.
>> Yeah. I feel the same way.
I mean, we're very
much limited by data.
When we have a very limited
amount of data,
then you can come
up with all kinds
of theories for it and
it's overdetermined to many
of your theories fit the data.
So, we're always trying
to collect more data,
and I wanted to make these
kind of theories and models
but spent most of my time
improving the data,
and I had, I think,
some success with that.
But if I felt that we
were really at the point
where we could record
millions of neurons,
pour through the data,
and try and analyze it,
and we knew the data
was accurate,
and we could correlate
it to stimuli
in human behavior and
the thoughts in humans had,
then we could really
have a mature science
of neuroscience.
Probably, if that was the case,
then I would have
stayed in the field.
But I really felt we were limited
in what we could do and what
we could record in that.
Actually, AI was answering
our questions in
more interesting ways.
>> So, I think for
people like you and I,
AI is our neuroscience right now.
>> Yeah. I would say so.
>> Moving into your work
to an AI company
going from a postdoc,
I guess into Baidu,
is going to distinct the jump.
>> Yeah.
>> How did that happen exactly?
>> Yeah. So, I mean very
much kind of just as
you just mentioned,
I ended up picking up
a fair amount of ML
along the way when
we were doing like spike signal
sorting for the neural arrays,
or just as you mentioned,
just the pure signal
processing tasks,
never even mind the neuroscience,
ends up using a lot of
machine learning and
pattern recognition.
So, I would say it was like
an amateur in the field,
but not someone who didn't
know no anything about it.
Then when I found out about
this effort at Baidu,
it's kind of just as it
was getting started.
I felt like it was
really an opportunity,
so I went away and
studied convolutional neural nets
and recurrent neural nets
for awhile and ended up getting
hired and I really enjoyed
it and never looked back.
>> In your work on
speech for the leaps
that you're able to push out,
what were some of
the techniques and insights
that helped you out
there in terms of getting
those new results?
>> Yeah. So, fair
amount of it was
just kind of pure
scale and engineering,
so I was more in
the ML side but also worked
with the systems folks.
So, I think one of
the things that
the Baidu lab was successful
at was using Synchronous
Stochastic Gradient Descent
before other people did.
>> Can you describe
what that means?
>> Yeah. So, basically,
the standard, the way,
kind of, AI result first
started coming out of
Google in Toronto in 2012.
The standard thing was
Asynchronous Gradient Descent.
So, this was done within
Google very much kind of like
the web server model
where each machine
has a batch and each machine
computes the gradient to
that batch and there's
some central server
that has the value of
all the parameters.
>> Parameters server.
>> Yeah, parameter server.
The gradients get applied and
so it's asynchronous
because I can be
calculating the gradients of
one model and apply it to
some new model that's been
updated in the meantime.
Synchronous gradient
descent is more like,
I have all these machines,
they compute gradients,
they do a Big-O reduce,
sum up all the gradients and
apply that gradient, everything.
So, the whole set of
machines takes one big step,
and then one big step,
and then one big step.
That turns out to have
benefits in terms of kind of
reproducibility and also seems
to in some contexts
lead to better results.
>> Do you think part of that
was the advancing
computation at the time?
>> Yeah. That's about what
I was about to get to.
A lot of the stuff we did in
speech was just our ability
to kind of scale things up,
use more compute,
collect more data.
We even kind of made
these graphs of how
much better do you
do as a result of number
of parameters if
the architecture is right,
number of- the
amount of amount of
data that you use and you see
these very smooth log plots.
After I left Baidu, they
explored this some more and it
turned into this paper called
Deep Learning Training.
Deep learning scaling
is predictable
empirically and that's been
one thing that's
shaped my thinking
that kind of once you know,
once you have the paradigm
for how to solve
a particular task.
Once you have all the
conceptual stuff right
then the scaling has the super
smooth properties to it.
>> Now, it's clear that there's
been for a number of
years now, excitement,
exuberance, about
the possibilities
of breakthroughs in AI
also fears, anxieties,
and these different opinions
on which way things might
go and whether there
are deep concerns to be
grappled with or it's
time to celebrate
immortality through the advent of
powerful machinery that we
can jump into some day
for some people
have captured the attention of
the public and
some technologists and
some scientists and I'm
curious if that was
the context in which you
start working in safety.
Well, how did you get
going on safety front?
>> Yeah. So, I think I was
kind of aware of some of
the kind of more extreme views
in terms of safety.
In many cases, I
thought people were,
it was true kind of like jump
ahead of themselves
or not thinking about
the problem in the right way.
But at the same time,
I thought that there
was really a kernel
of important truth to
some of what they
were saying which is
that if you have
a powerful AI system,
and today we have
somewhat powerful
AI systems but they're
getting more and more
powerful every day.
If that system does
has goals, objectives,
that are not aligned with
the ones you want them to be,
that can lead to accidents,
to catastrophic behavior.
My perspective on it,
the perspective that
I hope I've helped to kind
of bring to the safety field
is this empirical perspective of
let's look at today's systems,
if you think of some problem
that you might have
in the future,
some safety issue
that you might have
with future powerful AI systems,
can you kind of build
a replica of that
today in today's systems to study
the problems conceptually
and build kind of
durable safety
approaches so that if
the AI system gets more powerful,
the safety approach gets
powerful along with
it and someday we'll
have super intelligent machines
and then I hope that day,
that on that day
we've been spending
many years making the safety
systems better and better.
So, it's a problem that
when we finally do face it,
we do know how to
grapple with it.
>> I think it's, just to
reflect a bit in real-time,
there are different often
unstated intuitions
about what the concerns
are notions of something
might go wrong and there's
some costly outcome but
it's noticed and seen
and people set the system down or
they addressed an issue and
make the system better.
There's the idea of something big
happens and it's hard
to ever stop it and
it's a long-term oppression
of human beings and
there's a third notion of,
many more, of something is going
wrong under the hood
and implicitly it's
creating some nuances
in the world that
make us unhappy as
individuals or is
costly to the society
like even how automation
might shift cause more inequity
in wealth for example.
I'm curious which sort
of where you think
you're concerned, I mean
what you're addressing?
>> All of the above to
different degrees, right?
So, I think there could be kind
of unitary problems or rebuild
a specific AI system
where we wanted
to do X and then instead does Y.
>> But that's noticed?
>> Yeah, and it's noticed
but maybe something
catastrophic happens
before we notice it and we
corrected but damage was done,
I mean, this is the case
in self-driving cars.
They have problems,
people crashes,
eventually some people
will die, already have.
Then if we increase the stakes
to systems that are
making important decisions
for the economy,
the financial system,
humanity as a whole,
these kind of discrete danger
certainly can happen.
At the same time, there's kind of
like diffusion throughout
the economy of
AI systems like subtly
changing society in some way,
or changing the economy,
or changing how humans
relate to each other,
in a way that's like
could be really
bad but that we don't
notice right away.
I mean I'm very- I think there
are opportunities
for that as well.
Of course, there are
also opportunities
for AI to have
positive effects of
that type to help humans
make better decisions,
to understand themselves better,
to do all kinds of
things like that.
So, I see both the
positive and the negative.
>> In the paper, you
wrote a few years ago.
I think this was, maybe
you're coming out,
manuscript that
you will be taking
a serious look at
safety issues as a co-author.
You mentioned five concrete
types of problems you saw.
I think you had mentioned
and talked a little
bit about these concerns.
>> So, the one that
people ended up,
liking the most was
reward hacking.
So, it's this idea that you're
trying to get an AI system
to do something complicated like,
some complicated human
activity like just some,
I can't think of an example
off the top my head,
but you have some simple
proxy, I don't know.
An example would be like
trying to help humans
connect to each other
better or something
like that or make humans happier.
You have some simple
proxies that are
usually correlated
with it and you
start to optimize one of
the proxies and as you
do more and more
optimizing of the proxy,
it kind of starts to diverge in
the thing you're
ultimately trying to get.
Like a lot of tech products,
it's really easy to
measure like engagement
or clicks and they're
kind of used as
a lazy proxy for the user
is getting what they want and
users enriching themselves.
That's maybe true before
you optimize heavily for
it but once you optimize
heavily for it that
correlation can break and
so noting that this
is a general problem
for Reinforcement
Learning Systems
and whatever comes after
Reinforcement Learning Systems,
RL Plus Plus, it's
a general feature of systems
that are throwing a lot of
optimization power and compute
to pursue a unitary goal.
>> You showed
a really expressive video
of what one of your systems
did when it discovered
how to hack a value function
or objective I should
say more generally.
We can describe that game
and the result.
>> Yeah. So, it's
this boat race game.
I probably shown this video
a bunch of times.
>> The people haven't
seen that you just sort
of click on that link,
they'll find it somewhere.
>> Yeah, so it's like this boat
is supposed to be completing
this boat race and
the way it's setup is,
I was training this among
hundreds of other games.
So, I didn't look too closely at
the reward function but
the way it's setup
within the game is
you get points for hitting
these targets along the along
the course and then
points for finishing the race
and so you would think,
well that incentivizes, it's not
quite the same as saying
finished the race,
but you would think
it would incentivize
the agent to finish the race.
But it turns out they're
both confined to
this isolated lagoon
and basically spin
around in this perfectly
designed circle in order
to keep getting these power
ups just as they regenerate.
It can get such a high density
of points that it's like I don't
even need to finish the race
I'm just going to find
this lagoon and spin
around in it forever.
>> It's certainly showing in
that video is a way to you
can save 30 minutes
of a presentation
to say, "Look at this video."
Here's what happened
with these methods
to push the point
through very clearly.
Other of these challenges
to AI systems in
the open world include
notions that I would say are
captured by the classic
frame problem in AI.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's talk about the notion
that AI systems really didn't
have enough knowledge
to understand
the current state,
the qualification problem.
When they took an
action in the world,
they really didn't understand
the ramifications,
given how much knowledge
you would need to
understand all the possible
effects of action.
I get the sense that, that
could characterize a lot
of what we're seeing
now in modern AI
as we work with
these probabilistic systems.
>> Yeah. No, I think
it's very true I mean
it's what I had in mind with
some of the safety problems.
That the world is
a really big place
and agents or agent brains
are relatively small,
human's brains are
a relatively small.
There's much more in
the world that can
ever fit in your head.
Also at least for our
reinforcement learning agents,
the reward functions
are even smaller.
So, there's no way
we're going to capture
all the subtlety.
Even humans are not going
to understand the world.
They have a bunch of heuristics,
they have a bunch of
ways to compress it,
but even then it's
not perfect and then,
if we're crippling things
further by having
these very hacky proxies for
reward functions that just seems
to me like a recipe for
things going wrong.
>> If you could just reflect now,
I think you spent
time today doing
your distinguished lecture
talking about
your current direction
which is to figure out
just a very shared goal
with Microsoft Research.
If it's in this realm,
how to weave human intellect into
the process of designing
and guiding these systems?
Say a little bit
more about how that,
what spark that whole direction
in your work right now.
>> So, I think
the original work on that
about a year and a half now
was myself and one of
the people in my group,
Paul Christiano, who
had been writing.
On one hand Paul had
been writing about
things similar to
this for a while.
I got very excited about
from the safety perspective,
and I think there's also
a fairly rich academic literature
on putting humans into
the training loop,
but a lot of it
hadn't caught up to
the power of RL systems
and it hadn't been done
for deep learning.
We really didn't know if it was
something that worked at scale.
So, we said, "Let's see if on
modern RL tasks and
modern AI systems,
we can make this,
put humans in the loop
during training
in order to tell AI systems what
their goals should be and
what human values they should
embody and then at test time,
the agents can act
completely autonomously."
This seemed like
a really appealing approach
because it means
the AI system can
in the end act
completely autonomously,
but because it's interactive
with humans during training,
it embodies a picture of
human values and human
directives and goals.
So, we spent a few months
trying to get that to work
and found that for a lot of
the modern RL task we could,
in fact get it to work.
So, a lot of
our work more recently
has branched off that.
>> It seems that there's several
different approaches to that.
We've done a number of
projects where we try to
characterize human intellect,
characterize machine intellect,
understand blindspots,
understand what each agent
does a great job
and understand how
to do the handoffs or
the synthesis of
these intellection.
The interesting work you
just talked about was
about for example,
humans providing hence feedback,
shaping of the utility function,
and request reward.
It seems that there are
several different ways to
go in this fund.
So, what are some interesting
directions there?
>> So, as you mentioned
the original paper
was like agent gives
some examples of,
what its behavior to
the human and then ask
which of these are best?
What is more like, what
you want me to do?
In the original paper was
like a binary choice.
It was like is left
better or the right
better> Now we're expanding
in various directions.
Thought is, can the human give
feedback to the AI system
in natural language?
Or can it give feedback
more indirectly?
Can one AI system help a
human understand how to
train another AI system?
So, that's a more
complicated way of having
humans and existing AIs work
together to train
more powerful AIs.
We're also thinking of
going into more like
language focus direction.
We're thinking of combining
it with other techniques.
The common technique in
reinforcement learning
is imitation learning where human
demonstrates a task a bunch
of times and AI system
looks at that and tries to
copy it or learn what
the human is doing.
So, that's another way
to get humans involved.
I think our general vision is,
let's work to try
and find ways to
combine all of
these features together.
Because it's a little
how children learn,
they learn by copying adults,
they learn by getting feedback on
whether what they're
doing is good or not,
sometimes they just know
the answer and they learn
from that and it's not
really any one thing,
it's a mix of all those things.
>> What is some your thoughts on
applying these methods someday to
build a system that has
the ethical insights and
wisdom that we might expect
from a sage we look
up to when it comes
to hard decisions.
>> Yeah. I mean that's
the ultimate ambition
of this sort of thing.
I mean, obviously
there's a lot of
things between what we
can do now and that,
just as there's a lot
of things between
today's AI systems and AI systems
that are as good as
humans and everything.
But I think we're trying
to gradually scale up,
introduce new methods,
make progress by pieces.
I think one feature that
will be really important
is in using humans
to train AI systems,
there are number of
biases that humans
have and a number of
limitations in
humans understanding
their own values and being able
to impart their own values.
So, we're actively looking for
collaboration with
social scientists,
behavioral psychologists,
cognitive scientists, economists,
those types of people to
help us to design
those experiment.
We think this isn't purely
a technical problem,
it has like a social
science component to it.
As well, we're hoping
increasingly as we move to
harder tasks to get
social scientists more involved.
>> I get the sense that you're
an optimist overall about
where technology is
going, is that true?
>> I mean,
I think I'm an optimist overall,
in the sense that
I think if we're
thoughtful about how
to use technology,
that if we think
really hard about,
it is possible to
get a good outcome.
At the same, I hesitated
a little because I think
it really depends in us and it
depends on how things are used.
Right, if I look at the way a lot
of social media stuff
was rolled out,
and just the effects it's had
on democracy and elections over
the last few years like we
didn't think about any of
that stuff ahead of
time and as a result,
while these technologies
have had positive impacts,
we're starting to see
their negative side
as well, and so,
it's hard to be
like a starry-eyed,
unmitigated optimist when
you see that all around you.
But, the lesson I
take from it is that,
with AI we shouldn't
let that happen,
we should instead think
about everything,
we should think about
the downsides ahead of time,
we shouldn't have a culture where
we attack people for thinking
about the downsides.
It's like an important
function that, I think,
is actually core to actually
getting the technology to work,
actually getting it to
deliver its benefits,
and that if we don't have
these thoughts and if we don't
have these conversations,
then there's going
to be this backlash.
>> So, let's push on
optimism for a second.
Just speculate with me
if 15-20 years from now,
what do we see, where are we with
AI in terms of
applications, theory?
>> Yeah. i mean, I think
in terms of applications, I mean,
you mentioned we both
share this background
of having thought
about neurobiology and
just the structure
of the brain and the structure
of biochemistry,
you really get this sense
looking at the
problems of biology,
that they're beyond
human scale, right.
You look at these charts of
metabolism, every cell has.
>> Don't remind me of having
to memorize all that stuff.
>> Yeah. It's terrible.
You know, every cell has
7,000 different kinds
of proteins that get
expressed out of
30,000 or so genes
and some proteins have one copy,
some half a million copy,
some of them are
like phosphorylated,
some of them aren't, and it's
just no human can remember it.
There's all this data, we're
using machine
learning a little bit
to analyze pieces of
the data but really,
it seems to me
that this is
almost a problem tailor
built for machines, and so,
I'm hopeful and I've
heard other people,
even at Microsoft saying
the same thing and
I think it's a correct
optimistic vision.
I really hope that we can
use AI to take over more
of a scientific process,
maybe someday all of
the scientific process and
cure long standing diseases
like cancer that just
have this complexity,
that we have a hard time
reckoning with.
Similarly, for things like
global warming or
energy problems,
just technology
problems in general
which all told humans aren't
really that great at.
>> So, that's 25 years from now.
>> Yeah.
>> Something costly
has happened that
people say that was
a problem with AI.
>> Yeah.
>> What's your best guess
what had happened over
that period of time?
>> I mean, there's lots of
kinds of things that
could go wrong,
I mean, I think,
when I think about
the accident stuff.
Right, there's
the most extreme scenario
is the world gets destroyed,
and I think that there are
scenarios where
that could happen.
For instance, if
you had AI systems
managing nuclear weapons
or something like that,
for a country turned over it's
national defense to AI or
something like that and the
in the AI wasn't well-designed
in the sense that
it didn't even do what
it was designed to do,
systems that are supposed
to manage the economy.
If we really get to
the point where we're
really putting the whole
world's trust in AI systems,
then I do think there are
extreme outcomes
that could happen.
On the less extreme side,
just things like
economic crashes,
systems being unsafe causing
individual casualties on
the social misuse and
responsibility side.
I think the potential invasiveness
of AI technology could
have a lot of concerns
related to pervasive surveillance
and things like that,
just misuse of AI in general
by nation states in
changing the world
role balance of power.
>> So, turning from your
thoughts about the future to
maybe some current questions
from some folks watching this,
especially with regards
to career you've had
such an illustrious career even,
given how early you
are in your career,
going through many different
phases of interests,
following the natural terrain
of your curiosity,
I'm curious what your advice
might be to folks thinking
about their major in college
or graduate work and beyond?
>> Yes. So, I mean
I definitely think
that AI machine
learning is going to
continue to be just a big player
in the general advance
of technology.
I mean, even if we stopped
all research advances today,
just the pure applications
of what we already have
would be economically
transformative,
and I don't think that
the research advances are going
to ground to a standstill.
So, I think it's a very
promising career direction.
I really encourage people
to think about
the social implications,
just the number of undergrads
and young people do
seem to already be
thinking about that.
So, it seems like people are
thinking in the right direction.
I've just met a lot of
people who seem like they
just genuinely care
about both advancing
the technology and
making sure that
it's good for the world.
One piece of advice I have is,
I really think ML and
Al and are becoming
much more hands on
fields and instead
of waiting to take
grad school courses in them or
that sort of thing that just
like checking out GitHub repos
for like all the latest models,
trying to implement
them yourself,
trying to tinker with
them yourself, I mean,
I think it started as just as
like programming used to be
academic computer science
and then you move
to become more of a
practical discipline,
I think AI or many parts of
AI are much more moving
to be this kind of
practical discipline that it's
about your ability
to pattern match
and so you want to get cycles
of iteration in very early,
you want to implement
lots of stuff,
you want to know
models back and forth.
You also need to know the theory
but there's less of that
than there used to be,
and a lot of it is
starting to consolidate.
>> Well, great. Well, it is
fabulous talking to you today.
Thanks very much, Dario.
>> Thanks for having me.